in the first years of interaction
between native americans and europeans
there were a lot of aspects of each
other's cultures that each group found
well just plain weird europeans and
native americans looked
dressed and thought differently in
fundamental ways that led to
misunderstandings and even violence
between them so let's take some time to
compare some ways in which native
american cultural ideas differed from
european cultural ideas so how is it
possible to make a direct comparison
between native american cultures and
european cultures
one way is to choose a few categories
of social interaction and belief
and identify how each group conceived of
them here i've chosen ideas about land
and property ownership
gender roles and religion as areas to
compare now before we start i want to
put a big asterisk here and say that
these are generalizations
just as the english french spanish dutch
didn't have all exactly the same
religion or concept of proper gender
roles the algonquians iroquois pueblos
and mississippians weren't identical
either but there were some similarities
among european groups
and among native american groups that
allow us to compare and contrast them
more broadly so let's start identifying
these differences
and exploring what effect they may have
had on how the two groups perceived and
interacted with each other one major
difference between europeans and native
americans was in their ideas about land
ownership to europeans land was owned by
individuals and passed down through
families
they had the right to fence off a plot
of land and prevent trespassing for
native americans land ownership was less
defined and more temporary
one tribe might claim control of a
hunting range
or one family might farm a plot of land
for a season but they didn't own it
forever
most land was free for everyone to use
but not to own
so when europeans arrived native
americans might agree to let them farm
and hunt in their territories but they
didn't expect that europeans would then
fence off that land and prevent others
from using it likewise europeans were
confused when native americans continued
to use land that they thought they had
purchased to own forever native
americans also tended to have a more
communal approach to property and trade
to them trading relationships were
important and they required a lot of
feasting and gift-giving to cement ties
between tribes europeans were frequently
frustrated by the amount of pomp and
circumstance native americans demanded
to complete what they saw as a simple
business transaction partly this had to
do with how native americans viewed
property in general while europeans
gained high status in society by owning
a lot of things and therefore being rich
native americans achieved high status by
giving a lot of things away being a
source of riches for others so unlike in
europe where there were huge gaps
between the rich and the poor native
american societies were comparatively
egalitarian it was pretty rare for
someone to go hungry if their neighbor
had food to spare europeans couldn't
tell if native americans were just
naturally generous kind people or if
they maybe just didn't get how business
worked and to native americans europeans
seemed greedy and selfish allowing
others to starve and do without so that
they could enrich themselves differences
in gender roles also confused the groups
in european societies men were the heads
of household and they were in charge of
outdoor labor women took care of the
home but they also had relatively few
rights they couldn't participate
politically own property or get divorced
in native american societies men hunted
and fished and conducted warfare which
often meant that they were away from
home for weeks or months consequently
women did the farming since they were
home to tend the crops native women also
had a lot more freedom than european
women they could get divorced they could
give political advice to councils many
native american societies were
matrilineal so children belong to their
mother's family rather than their
fathers and when a couple got married
the man moved in with his wife's family
not the other way around to europeans
gender roles in native society almost
seemed like they were flipped upside
down and they took this as evidence that
native people were uncivilized to native
americans it looked like europeans could
barely care for themselves they had to
be taught how to farm how to fish even
how to hunt effectively in the new world
finally native and european religious
practices differed at least on the
surface native americans tended to
believe that one great creator had made
the world and that nature was imbued
with spirits who would reward or punish
them based on how well they took care of
the land in fact this actually wasn't
that much different from the catholicism
of europeans who believed in a single
god but also many helpful saints but
where they differed was in exclusivity
when europeans introduced them to jesus
and mary and the saints many native
americans were happy to include them in
their pantheon of helpful spirits but
this angered europeans who insisted on
exclusive worship of the christian god
all of these differences led to fraught
interactions between europeans and
native americans but despite these
differences they also adopted many
useful aspects of each other's culture
over time especially in terms of trade
native americans were keen to get their
hands on the metal implements for
cooking and farming and hunting that
europeans possessed as well as guns and
horses which were great for
transportation and also for making war
europeans were also willing to take part
in the social rituals and trading
rituals of native americans sometimes
even marrying into native american
families so they could get access to
furs hunted by native americans and to
native americans as allies in their wars
against rival european powers in the
americas so as we wrap up i encourage
you to take a closer look at this chart
is there anything you find particularly
surprising about these differences where
do you think that europeans and native
americans were most likely to find
common ground between them and lastly
which of these cultural aspects do you
think was the most significant
difference between europeans and native
americans and why